[La musique]
les gars lszh sentent que c'est officiel
quand tes japonais sont des bombes qui
avec votre ou singe dans le physio michelin
idée radicale oui oui tu après le pour
c'est tellement froid juste pour voir que Dieu est
eh bien c'est une longue journée tu es déjà un
facture marsipulami b
mon fils était un peu plus gentil que toi
montre lui ce que tu as
apportez-nous un sac de bouillon j'ai 18 heures d'école
huile marie et électroménager mais oui oui oui
sauna
[Applaudissements]
cet ensemble de cappuccino tu es déjà coincé avec ça
monter première recherche et normal
n'auriez-vous pas l'air de vos mères
boutique en ligne super merci après c'est un
trouve que je suis sûr que votre ironie est de
plus we quand j'ai mon variateur si oui oui
oui non quoi faire
[Applaudissements]
Oui
attends
Bien
Oui
haha
[Applaudissements]
pwc
sont alors à bordeaux contre désolé
tous partis
Bien
[Applaudissements]
[Rire]
pourquoi n'en aurait-il sûrement pas
tellement excité peut-être
[Applaudissements]